bonjour alexis heureux de vous retrouver
dans la matinale france alors l'épidémie
de commis de repart de plus belle en
europe avec des mesures de restriction
qui reviennent en france malgré une
vaccination élevé qu'est ce qu'il se
passe
eh ben on aimerait savoir alors on en
parlait à l'instant à l'autriche qui a
décidé de confiner les non vaccinés
alors confiné et c'est un grand mot
puisqu'ils ont le droit d'aller au
travail d'aller faire leurs courses en
gros bon ils n'ont pas droit aux loisirs
c'est un peu l'équivalent d'un pass
sanitaire en france on est à 75 % de
taux de vaccination et gabriel atta le
porte parole du gouvernement nous dit
attention on pourrait peut-être confiné
donc j'aimerais comprendre ce qui se
passe et je pense qu'on est nombreux à
vouloir comprendre parce que si on
regarde les chiffres et bien des pays
majoritairement vacciner comme
l'allemagne comme france alors
l'autriche un peu moins 1 62% de
vacciner au lieu des 65 % de moyenne
européenne on voit bien que l'épidémie
apparaît pourtant on a gardé le masque
un jour et nuit midi et soir été comme
hiver les gestes barrière le vaccin et
voilà qu'on nous parle de confinement
alors que le vaccin c'était 100%
l'assurance un qu'on arrêtait les
confinements nous disait olivier ferrand
mais on n'est pas un mensonge près vous
me direz le pass sanitaires on est haut
on est le 15 novembre et bien ils
devaient se volatiliser aujourd'hui bon
bah maintenant il est à peu prêt
jusqu'en juillet 2022 c'est assez
incroyable on a l'impression que
finalement les gouvernements européens
décident de se soigner avec des méthodes
de coercition pour pousser les gens à la
vaccination or le problème aujourd'hui
on le voit c'est que le vaccin ne
n'empêche pas la contamination la
propagation du virus il empêche
peut-être les formes graves pour
certains mais c'est encore loin d'être
la panacée d'ailleurs même bill gates 1
le dit il va peut-être falloir trouver
d'autres produits parce que là ça ne
marche pas comme on l'espérait alors la
question c'est pourquoi continuer à
faire ce qui ne fonctionne pas pourquoi
continuer à empêcher certains de vivre
rappelez-vous au début de l'épidémie il
était question certains avaient posé sur
la table 1 le fait de confiner les
personnes à risque on avait dit surtout
pas assez scandaleuse c'est pas ça la
république ses plats salés valeurs
européennes là on en est à confignon les
non-vaccinés visiblement c'est quelque
chose qui passe et qui est partagé par
certains candidats à l'élection
présidentielle xavier bertrand et
valérie pécresse qui sont prêts très dur
avec les non vaccinés pour là encore les
confiner alors même que rappelons le le
vaccin n'empêche pas la propagation du
virus on ne comprend pas pourquoi on
continue avec ces mesures sanitaires qui
sont en train de patauger et de
finalement limité à la marge la
propagation de cette épidémie et du bon
sens quelles sont les perspectives
économiques face à cette flambée alexis
le durcissement des règles de calcul de
l'allocation chômage on vient de le voir
est appliquée depuis le 1er octobre mais
l'entrée en vigueur de certaines
dispositions de la réforme soumise à
l'amélioration du marché de l'emploi ne
se fera que le premier des cent est ce
que c'est le bon timing selon vous
pas du tout d'ailleurs s'est discutée au
conseil d'état les syndicats continuent
de critiquer cette mesure de de moins
disant social qui va plonger dans la
précarité de nombreux français elisabeth
bornes qui sort des chiffres 1 du
chapeau il n'y a jamais eu aussi peu de
chômage ces fausses chômage de catégorie
a certes mais il ya toujours autant de
chômeurs en france avec bien des postes
qu'on n'arrive pas à pourvoir parce que
des boulots sous payés ou bien trop loin
des lieux de travail de certaines
personnes c'est pareil a pas il n'y a
pas de bâton magique pour arrêter avec
le chômage ce qu'on voit simplement
c'est que les gouvernements l'état
essaye de faire des économies sur le dos
des plus précaires c'était le cas déjà
avec la réforme des apl c'est le cas
avec la réforme de l'allocation chômage
qui va mettre les permis tant les
travailleurs saisonniers et autres dans
l'embarras dans une précarité
grandissante
parce que ces règles ne sont pas pensés
pour ces gens là et parce que l'activité
économique si elle a l'air de reprendre
en contre jour on ne sait pas où nous
allons on voit bien que quand on a un
pays comme l'autriche qui hélas a
confiné certains membres de sa
population l'épidémie qui reprend on ne
sait pas du tout dans quel état va être
l'économie on al impression là qu'on est
dans un sorte de récit qui prépare la
réélection demeurer le maquereau ou tout
va bien ou c'est formidable ya plus de
chômage on est à un taux de croissance
de 6% bon c'est toujours moins que avant
la crise qu vide
mais tout va bien madame la marquise
jusqu'à sans doute juin 2022 après
l'élection donc c'est assez cruel de
voir que d'un côté pour les plus
précaires pour les plus loin du marché
du travail on coupe les allocations et
pour les entreprises vient le prêt
garanti par l'état lui il est prolongé
jusqu'en juin 2022 après les élections
donc cet étonnant de voir que l'économie
il va bien pour certains et moins bien
pour d'autres c'est un choix encore là
totalement politique qui est celui de la
pauvreté merci beaucoup alexis c'est l
édito d'alexis poulain ce matin dans la
matinale rt france